[Music]
this is star talk sports edition a
cosmic queries version we're going to
talk about the winter olympics
oh yeah and we got gary o'reilly
yeah did i play soccer in this in the
snow do they play soccer in the snow
yeah we will do it depends if if it's
too bad no because the ball doesn't roll
but uh yeah we'll play frozen and in the
snow i got you gotcha and chuck you
avoid cold weather at all cost
uh yes i i've it's a it's an homage to
my ancestors
in the depths of africa yes there's no
snow yes
yes all of uh for all that came out of
the serengeti i'm
i'm representing
[Laughter]
so
this is a very broad topic because we
want to talk about
uh the olympics in general the winter
olympics the events the fact that it's
in beijing
and
you know anytime we have a broad subject
like this there's only one go-to person
and that's our geek in chief the one and
only my friend and colleague charles
luke charles welcome back to star talk
for the hundred and zillion
thank you neil it's my pleasure thank
you hello gary hello chuck or should i
say lord nice
[Laughter]
oh my god you were on that episode yeah
does yes does everybody know that it was
major general deanna burt that uh
anointed chuck nice with this uh title
with the with the lordship she certainly
did
and it comes in
and i always forget and people remind me
uh so so charles you you are a professor
of uh astronomy and physics at the city
university of new york at staten island
and correct you recently been uh become
chair of the department is that correct
yes yes and uh it's been fun i i have
some great colleagues some wonderful
students and
if anybody watches uh the chair the tv
show that's become popular lately that's
like five percent of maybe my regular
life but um it's a lot of fun i have a
good time
okay so i i smell a reality show in the
making
where charles who really shows right
what this is about yeah we'll call it a
lounge
and charles i you know with hearing from
the grapevine you've got a podcast in
the making so we all look forward to
seeing that post and thank you thank you
you told me offline that it's called the
it's called the
universe
yes
i see the universe yes
uh
i didn't come up with it uh you know
family members around the dining room
table they were like why don't you call
it the universe i said really yeah sure
why not
it should be fun really looking forward
to it should be a lot of fun with
talking with um fun folks we'll have a
good time excellent excellent it's a
cosmic queries grab bag on the 2022
olympics taking place in beijing so so
the questions are open for anybody and
anything and gary chuck who between you
has the questions for us
we i think chuckles chuck and i can
share them between ourselves um let us
kick it off um
welcome to charles obviously great to
have you back
right michaela negus these are all
questions from our patreon listeners
sorry what you what you call me
michaela [ __ ] oh oh okay oh all right
i got nervous for a second all right
just working on my pronunciation here
i couldn't trip up on that one too
quickly so why does the temperature of
olympic ice need to be different for
figure skating speed skating and hockey
could an ingredient be added to the ice
to make it more ideal for the athlete's
example making it smoother harder softer
et cetera
why i didn't even know that chuck
charles did you know that
ice changes all the time sorry isis
is basically
basic fact it are all three of those
ices
pure water or have they added anything
to it
uh usually things have been added uh
they are often pure water uh but if they
are pure water even then there's changes
because they change the temperature they
freeze it at different temperatures hot
or cold just because something's
freezing doesn't mean that it stays at
that same sort of texture and
temperature the whole time this is
actually used on purpose in a lot of
different places uh there's a famous
example in ice hockey in college hockey
depending on where you go to play your
hockey the ice is either really fast or
really slow
uh depends on their team you know wait
is this like the deflate gate with with
yeah tom brady where you can know that
happens naturally neil so for instance
the canadians have charles back me up on
this if i'm if i'm right or wrong um the
canadians have
just historically hard ice but if you go
and play hockey in la and someone's left
these or the arena doors open for a
while and that hot air comes in it
affects the quality of the eyes it
totally does and the refrigeration
underneath the ice of course can be
strongly uh adjusted to any situation if
you have an indoor rink right so what
happens with indoor activities
establish here yeah right i just have to
establish here because i think some
people might not know this i think you
were hinting at it but let me just let
me just drive it home
water freezes at zero degrees celsius 32
degrees fahrenheit
and we call that ice
but you can have ice at any temperature
below that
and the properties are different
depending on what temperature the ice is
so ice is not ice is not ice it's it
depends on how
cold the ice is okay is that
i think i got that right yes okay now
the handle that is exactly true and at
what what temperature does it get down
to
gangsta wrap like iced tea and ice cube
well
nice that you should mention that on
titan right the moon of saturn the
temperature of the ice is hundreds of
degrees below zero fahrenheit and so the
water ice is as hard there as granite is
here on this earth so they build
mountains with it you can see
all kinds of geological features that's
built with water ice that you could not
do here because the moment what do you
mean they built the ice
alien i'm just gonna let that one built
that's an excellent point
they built the they built
[Laughter]
yes gary the temperature varies and each
rink
does its own thing and each sport has
its own regulations as to
what you were allowed to do in terms of
temperature in terms of additives in
terms of those sorts of things yeah the
hockey players don't like soft ice
because the puck doesn't move
soft ice think of the very large bulky
folks who like the wayne gretzky's of
the world would zip right by the slow
guys the slow guys like the softer ice
yeah and and uh there are famous or
infamous examples of really good hockey
teams with fast skaters going into a
visiting rink where the players are
slower and suddenly it's like they're on
molasses and you see like water that's
right
they're letting the air out of the ball
yeah
that's time
very kind of like that yeah so is there
is it possible to get ice
so hard
that
like a speed skater's blade
wouldn't even
allow it to turn like you would
literally skid across the ice instead of
skate across it
on earth's surface
probably not okay but elsewhere in the
universe for sure and absolutely
oh cool cool
okay so it's all about what kind of
speed they want so figure skating versus
hockey versus speed skating
that then it's it's pretty clear you
just you can put that on a chart you
kind of can yeah um yeah and remember
what the skates look like right a hockey
state is straight the blade is straight
the figure skate's got a little uh dvd
thing right at the tip so you can dig
into the ice and jump up and do your
spins and things like that and if your
ice is too hard then it doesn't make it
effectively right but if it's too soft
then you also can't dig very much
because you got this sort of layer of of
soft stuff so yeah people have to adjust
very very so charles one other thing
why are speed skates longer in their
blade
than hockey skates
i presume that has something to do with
the ability for you to push off and get
higher velocities going in a straight
direction right i mean gary you're
probably more expert about in terms of
the relationship between how long you
can push say off the ground or something
and thus how much stride you can get or
how much speed you can pick up the kind
of acceleration explosiveness is there a
relationship to the amount of time the
skate stays on the ice
and you're able to impart energy through
that so therefore a longer skate allows
you that fraction more contact with the
ice and therefore pushing energy in to
push to get push out
yeah i bet you that's true and if you
want to stop too a longer blade gives
you more when you're at at a 45 or a 90
degree angle you're able to break faster
right because you have more of a surface
with which to push friction against the
ice
all right so okay
we have a very curious audience neil all
right dylan or d leon if chuck prefers
me to pronounce it like that hello dr
tyson dr lou and our great comedic
co-host yes of course i love to ski and
i've always wondered something this is
from dylan of course snow and ice aren't
exactly the same things and we know ice
has a thin layer of water less than a
width of a bacteria he believes which
makes ice sports possible such as
skating does skiing also have to do with
pressure melting or is there something
else going on with snow wow
the answer is both are true
the
snow isn't right
first explain pressure melting
yeah well there is a
relationship where if you have more
pressure on water
or ice it is more likely to melt this is
untrue for most substances but the more
you push on something more or you push
on ice the more likely it is to to be
able to liquefy
this is a particular property of ice
which is rare amongst substances here on
earth and that allows us to be able to
do these things like skate across ice
with that tiny film of water
that bacteria with filled water that we
talk about but it's a very complicated
system wait what's the what is the
molecular transaction that's happening
happening where
pushing pressure causes melting because
that's how they make the big ice balls
for my scotch which is how they do it
right i never make a snowball you take
the snow you smoosh it whoa there's your
ice ball right i never i never
questioned it because i'm about to drink
some scotch so i don't care
but what is what is the molecular
transaction that the pushing
makes the melting well uh we should we
shouldn't get too deeply into the
specific chemistry right now because it
takes a long time to sort of make the
descriptions but basically
a water molecule is a v shape right it's
it's got the oxygen in the middle and
it's got two hydrogens off to the side
making kind of a v it's a polar molecule
like this and when ice freezes it has a
tendency just to touch on the hydrogen
bonds it doesn't want to just squish in
but it wants to form a hydrogen bond
lattice or a crystal and as a result it
winds up with extra space between the
molecules space that would not have
existed in its ordinary liquid form
okay and so that basically allows all
kinds of strange things to happen and so
snow is ice
ee
water right it's solid water but it's in
small crystals as opposed to one big
slab of solid material so when you pack
a whole lot of little things together
and you create a surface it's a
different surface altogether from if you
have a single slab of the same object
everything's stuck together the
difference between say
a sandstone walkway and a sandy beach
so
snow gives you even more variation
on say going across its surface than
the
sliding across a slab of ice
so
the answer to the question here is
indeed that snow
variations changes temperature pressure
weather wind will make all the
difference in the world when it comes to
a snow sport
but in fact if you if you ski a lot on a
fluffy snow slope it eventually
becomes sort of you've melted many of
the surface layers of crystals of of
snowflakes and eventually just becomes
icy it's no longer fun to ski you will
start packing it down more and more then
again if you're in competition neil you
want to go faster so i see quicker
fluffy powdery snow slower yep but but
there's a a very delicate uh equilibrium
that you have to find because if it's
too icy you can't turn
so in the giant slalom you want a kind
of nice balance between that powdery and
that icy so you can grip with the edges
of your ski but yet at the same time you
can achieve uh the the turning so you
have the fast and the turning at the
same time chuck you know the deal if
it's too high so you find the nearest
tree because you just started
right there but wait chuck we
established in a previous episode that
we're not taking skiing advice really
yes we are right now
who's sitting by the fire in the lodge
i'm sitting by the fire with some brandy
just like you do realize the reason you
weren't able to turn was because
before we take a break i want to add
something to what charles said so
because
water expands when it freezes
it can only exist in that expanded state
as ice
if you successfully squeeze it
it cannot be squosen as ice
the only way you can squeeze it is for
it to change state and then become
smaller in its volume
wow and so so so that's why so you're
skating on the ice the pressure forces
it to turn back into water even at the
lower temperature
wow that is exactly right and and then
the
if you're doing going down a ski slope
or a toboggan slope or you know like a
bobsled or something remember a lot of
that stuff is outdoors so what if it
starts to snow
then you have even more stuff on there
it gets even more complicated the
weather makes all the difference in the
world i remember uh 1984 i think it was
the sarajevo winter olympics billy
johnson the american was the first
person down the mountain
and then the weather got worse and worse
and worse and all the rest of the
competitors could not keep up with that
first time because that first time was
the ideal condition regardless of what
anything else happened with the surface
because the atmospheric conditions had
changed
cool dude all right we're going to take
a quick break when we come back more
cosmic queries grab bag on the winter
olympics with our geek in chief charles
liu
we're back star talk
sports edition cosmic queries grab bag
got charles liu
who's out who's our
go-to person anytime we're all just
confused about everything it's always a
pleasure to be here always fun to chat
with everybody
so so uh we're just pulling questions
out of this grab bag and uh that chuck
or or gary who's got the next one okay
i'll jump in um right eric varga says
hello dr tyson dr lou but he's
downgraded you chuck you're now sur
chuck you've lost you you've lost your
lordship apparently yeah yeah
i don't know that sir is less than lord
oh god yes yeah he does now or maybe
he's very well aware
all right
can you explain how newton's three laws
apply to the sport of curling are there
any other laws of physics involved that
play a vital role in advance he says
thanks
did the word sport and the word curling
show up in the same phrase absolutely
be such a snob curling is a distinguish
curling is one of the oldest team sports
in existence
look this show is going to come with a
history lesson whether you like it or
not right okay
okay first first invented in scotland
and the first documented documented
match was between a monk and an abbot in
paisley abbey in scotland in 1541 so the
moral the moral of this history is
when you lock people up in a monastery
for a long time during winter they come
up with curling
just
so about newton's three laws of physics
and anything else you can throw at
curling yes
well uh newton's three laws
as most of us know
is that first law right an object in
motion tends to stay in motion in a
straight line unless acted upon by an
outside force
so
the guy pushing the stone forward it's
just going to keep going and going and
going and that's why you notice that it
keeps going and going going unless acted
upon by an outside force
okay now the second law of motion uh
forces just to be clear it keeps going
because the friction is very low
otherwise the friction would stop it
right well so you are front running me
on that point you you're absolutely
right no no no it's good it's good see
because because you're doing exactly
what scientists should be doing right
which is jumping in and saying ah but
right and the butt is newton's second
law
which as you know is forces mass times
acceleration it's also sir mix-a-lot's
first law
i like big okay never mind
[Laughter]
what is creating the mass times
acceleration right that's the second
thing that's what neil is bringing up
and friction as it turns out will cause
mass times acceleration to be exerted on
the stone that's moving forward
and so the second law requires
that you wind up making sure that the
friction is just right so the amount of
force and acceleration that you get the
change in direction and the change in
speed is what you want so those guys in
the broom up front they are quickly
changing the coefficient of friction of
the ice on the whole time the the
brushing uh i i i've never known if
exactly before every run
the curling people uh put like a whole
bunch of snow or shaved ice on the track
no charles back in the 16th century when
curling was invented it was taken place
on lock frozen locks and frozen ponds so
what you have to have now with indoor
curling ice is pebbly
it's not a smooth silk finish it's
pebbly so what the guys with the brooms
are doing they are taking away those
pebbles as much as they can in a certain
way and the big clue about what this
sport's all about is in the title
curling right because a stone will curl
may be three times on its way to the
target or it might curl
10.
but the deviation is there
and therein lies the third law
newton's third law of motion when it
reaches its destination in the curled
direction it wants it hits other stones
and for every action there is an equal
and opposite reaction
that's newton's third law so the stone
hits the other stones that are in the
scoring area either knocks them out or
pushes them a little bit so newton's
laws of motion are involved in all
stages of this exciting thrilling super
fast
energy sport
yeah
let me just
let me just say this as a former janitor
curling is the best sport ever
wait so so charles something i never
thought about yeah so as they're
brooming material into the path of the
of the
i keep thinking curly iron curling
stones
they're they can
they can slow it down but they can't
speed it up because it only has the
speed it has at that moment but they can
also change its direction yeah
absolutely
they're putting more friction on one
side of it than the other right yeah
right so so the the physics of the
brooming people
is extremely significant
the the push once the the pusher pushes
the stone off his work is done
and all the rest of the team has to
figure out where to push it forward
based on the pebbliness or the shaviness
of the ice so
here's something to add to this
conversation as i think you'll
understand i don't get the chance to do
this very often but the curling stone is
not flat on the base it's actually
concave so it has a rim
around it so when it's traveling forward
the likelihood and please disprove me is
that there's a little tilt on the front
edge which causes a little bit more
friction and then you've got an added
rotation to the stone so is that making
sense to you charles as i well it does
in a in an important generalized way we
talk very glibly about ice melting and
pushing and things like that but
actually
the surface physics
the connections between surfaces of ice
and curling or skis or anything like
that is still rather poorly understood a
lot of it is still under experimentation
today at the highest levels what happens
when one surface touches another and
that physics right at the edge there
remains mysterious in a lot of different
ways so many hypotheses have to be put
forward and then they're either
confirmed or debunked depending on the
circumstances of the time but it's a
very complex question so what you bring
up is definitely an area for future
study and research i would add that if
you if you've ever gotten your brakes
changed on your car
generally the front brakes wear out
sooner than the rear brakes
because
when you stop the car
the momentum of the car is carried more
in the front wheels than in the back
wheels so the so gary i that that's
that's my conduit to what you said where
if it's going forward and there's any
friction slowing it down at all that
front edge is going to respond to it
more significantly than the rear edge uh
then again you'll have to go from front
engined vehicles to mid-engine vehicles
where there's weight distribution but
that's another conversation for another
time but i think charles you you've
given us an idea what do you know about
that in a rear-wheel car
isn't it still the front
brakes that get most of the
it varies a lot again um if you're
driving
just just move the engine to the back
right well it depends on if you're
moving on a flat surface or whether
you're climbing hills
are you stopping a lot while you're
going upward or downward you are pushing
more of your your mass and first forward
to the front because a a car even though
it feels like a rigid body actually has
a great deal of give to it right a lot
of springs a lot of flexible parts to it
so
it's not a dead set thing with with our
typical driving in suburbia for example
i think neil you're right on but uh the
complexity of driving gives us all
plenty of uh fodder or area to be right
what
what about the flintstone cars
well
you should check out fred's heels yeah
now those brake pads are some serious
calories
all right let's let's jump to another
question um on all these questions from
our patreon listeners so we're grateful
for that artist formerly known as james
smith hellos doctors and lords chuck
congrats on your land in scotland so
there you go quick question bobsledding
is an awesome sport to watch how many
g's are the bobsledders experiencing at
top speed and also are there zambonis
for their eyes like in skating
that's cool
good question cool um yes the
is let's see the zamboni question first
there actually is a lot of grooming of
bobsled runs ooh i do not know exactly
whether they drive a vehicle down can
you imagine like a little crawler
i do not know if that's the answer but
they pour water down them they sculpt
them there are things that are made and
change the channels are changed the
temperature is controlled so there is a
lot going on that's zamboni like
on a bobsled run that's a hundred
percent true and during the competition
there are
like track grooves that are created by
the former runs
and you have to actually compensate for
the track grooves that are already there
the person who is actually pulling the
the two chords drivers the driver yeah
yeah so yeah you're absolutely right at
the fireplace sipping scotch
once again i'm i'm down to the lodge up
just like you do realize that you didn't
account for the track grooves this is
your problem sir
also i want to add one thing before we
take a quick break the g-forces you feel
have nothing to do with how fast you're
moving oh they have to do with how fast
your velocity is changing
so
um their biggest g force is charles
they're going to be like on when they
bank the term right right a g
right a g is the acceleration rate of
9.8 meters per second squared the amount
of acceleration you feel when you're in
free fall near the surface of the earth
i did a quick calculation just now in
the past 30 seconds in my head so i'm
not sure if it's exactly right you can't
quote me on this but
based on what i think how fast they're
going down the hill the angles of the
turns and the velocities and and the
banks and so forth you're probably
hitting at least three and sometimes
four
times of gravity so
30 to 40 meters per second squared of
acceleration so three or four g's is my
top of the head answer uh how to go back
and do more calculation to make sure
cool
all right let's take a quick break when
we come back more with charles lew our
geek in chief
who's breaking down the physics of the
winter olympics when star talk returns
we're back star talk cosmic queries
sports edition
the winter olympics all kinds of
questions we're good here so who's got
the latest one
all right here we go next up kevin the
sommelier ah hello chuck cube and gary
this is yo you're going to love the
ending on this one now this is not so
much a science question but a scientific
seinfeldian observation does the luge
and the skeleton well we'll see does the
luge and the skeleton events just seem
like a drunk friend's dare keep drinking
up
there yeah i thought you'd like that
kevin the similarity
i am certain the luge is for crazy
people
you can imagine someone up up the top of
a mountain
sat next to chuck with an empty bottle
of scotch says
it says that that tray over there i
could beat you to the bottom of the
mountain
okay yeah i feel like luge is like safer
right but how many of you have you all
going down a hill in in in a sledding
how many of you have you uh three of you
gone sledding before i mean we have all
been children charles yes
we've not done it on an ice track right
on an ice track as an adult no you know
or no the closest i came to that once i
was on an icy hill all right it was
maybe 40 foot tall
it was fantastic
you know how
i learned from chuck yesterday
there's common sense
and there's black people accents okay
there's
and so as an adult if you're going to
say sit on this tray and go down this
icy tube
at 199 miles an hour we're going to just
say no okay
my answer is you tell me to go down a
tube head first at 100 plus miles an
hour my answer is why don't you just
shoot me i'm here
why am i going to do the work for you
why am i doing the work for you you want
to kiss me
[Laughter]
i don't have the sense i'm sorry but i'm
really glad in that instance i didn't
because going down that hill
basically ice on basically a sheet of
plastic at a gazillion miles an hour was
one of the most fun and exhilarating and
awesome things going on and there are
other people many of them kids but also
some adults going by me some up fast or
some of them slower we're kind of some
of them piled up at the end of the hill
it was so much fun charles you know who
gets to say that the people who didn't
die
yeah
there is a survivor bias
just to tap the brakes just to tap the
brakes pun intended on this uh for
illusion the skeleton
they don't have any
yeah there's no brakes on the luge or
the skeleton so there's there's the
chance of an impact which is like my
best thought well you know we we
shouldn't understate the danger
every year professional losers are
killed professional skeletoners and
bobsledders are you know they die from
making much money i'm so glad you said
that charles because
it's the only sport where they don't
show you when it goes wrong nascar
formula one things go wrong you see the
car disintegrate break apart and then
you see the guy crawl out of the cage
even for years abcy world of sports had
a guy coming off a st
you will never see
anybody like promote
what happens when the luge goes wrong
yeah cause it would be ugly yeah because
the guy shoots out of the two very very
ugly yeah no they don't even care they
don't even follow it with the camera the
guy shoots out of the tube and then the
cameraman goes some things
there are some things all right let's
move on and uh
launched okay yeah okay this wouldn't be
the same with a sports edition grab bag
if we didn't have video letter and mum
izzy asking a question
she has now dubbed herself as astro
fizzy kid
oh
yeah okay she's like 18 by now and she's
been asking questions like 13 and one
half neil okay 13 and a half okay fine
yeah all right the question is we're not
being catfished and one day we find out
that via letter is like a 43 year old
dude
hello neil hello charles gary yes my
name is view letter and i have a
question
what are some of the craziest sports
past or present ever to be included in
the winter olympics
um i can't imagine there was throwing
the axe while skating on ice but that
sounds like it should have been back in
the day i i will enter one in one one
one sport in here the 90 meters ski jump
i am going up a really really high tower
i am icing down a skew slope and jumping
and trying to fly
now if that isn't crazy then i don't
know what it is no isn't she talking
about events that are no longer there or
just are we picking crazy events that
they have pastor present pastor
president right so so charles are there
defunct sports in the winter olympics as
there are in the summer olympics like
they don't have the tugging
or the rope climb after you know we did
this kind of question for the summer
olympics in the previous episode after
that i went and took a look at the
previous sports because i just found it
so fascinating and here is the one that
i found for winter olympics which i
think is the wildest and most
interesting one
it's called mountain military patrol
really in 1924
winter olympic games there was a sport
called military patrol where four
military officers one officer one
non-commissioned and two privates
carrying backpacks totaling at least 50
pounds
and carrying rifles except for the
officer who cares
uh the officer carries a pistol and no
backpack
yeah
right
and he's got a snowmobile
the four of them together had to climb
at least 3 000 feet in elevation
on cross-country skis going at least 15
miles
and then once they got there shoot
then do target practice okay that sounds
to me just like a way that america found
to invade another country
but this is french this is swiss oh
these are the swiss this is european oh
so this this would have been so this
will have involved the officers sitting
at a table while the privates practiced
their shooting and
he drank cognac and while eating brie
i couldn't tell you but apparently this
was a sport
it showed up again as a demonstration
sport several times later but it has
been discontinued since about 19 if i
remember 48 was the last time was a
demonstration but imagine that a sport
where you have a team of military
officers skiing and then climbing and
then shooting at various times we're all
carrying heavy backpacks
that's a sport so that became the the
cross-country pentathlon i guess what's
the one where they they they it's
biathlon today
evolved to a biathlon where you ski
shoot ski shoot ski shoot but nowadays
those
those rifles are very light caliber
they're they're they're heavy yes but
much less heavy than a true machine gun
or or a weapon that that actually a
military person used to use and now that
it's really a streamlined sport
that combines the uh skill of shooting
target shooting to not actually military
shooting the charge you sound like you
know swimming the grandpa on the porch
back in my day the rifles were heavier
and we had to climb up hill both ways
and then shoot
now
[Laughter]
i have been very fortunate in my life
never have to fire any kind of weapon
in anger and so i cannot speak for what
is easier or more difficult all right
what a qualifier charles what a
qualifier i know right in anger i shot
the guy after i calmed down
[Laughter]
let that one go all right do we have
time for another one hopefully uh yeah
yeah stewart
hello's dr tyson and lou um what impact
chuck and i we're not here uh what
impacts will climate change have on
winter olympics throughout the rest of
the century of course some sports are
already played indoors like skating and
curling but might we see an end to
sports that require outdoor cold
temperatures
you'll see an end to them in different
parts of the world where they
traditionally exist
uh remember with global warming like 100
million atomic bombs worth of extra
energy floating around in the atmosphere
at any given time right for every degree
change in celsius
there's going to be a lot of motion so
some parts that were traditionally cold
will get warm and some parts that are
traditionally warm will get colder
right so
in switzerland for example or in parts
of france the famous uh ski areas
chamonix you know places like that
they're already having real trouble
getting enough snow to have a decent
recreational ski season so their sports
seasons have been severely curtailed
already and that's true
other places where currently nobody goes
to though maybe certain areas of
mountaintop certain places where polar
vortices coming out from different parts
of the arctic will create new flows of
cold those areas might get much more
snow and much more ice than they do
today yeah but but nobody's got a ski
slope up there yet so that this might
change the business landscape the entire
landscape will change you're going to
have a world where the sports will still
continue but they'll be in completely
different places places where there are
no ski slopes or
winter resorts today there will be there
and in other places where there were for
decades maybe even centuries those
places will struggle welcome to the 2050
olympics of winter here in fiji
[Laughter]
uh it's gonna be weird it's gonna be
strange we all have to adapt
by this time the show goes out we'll
have done our ice and snow show and we
have a uh a great guest dr peter veals
who makes artificial snow so maybe he is
on the he is the vanguard of a boom
industry
making powder snow we shall see uh right
one more question
slip in one more gary see if we can get
it all right anna c hickman hello all i
have a question about paralympic
athletes and a future time somewhere
when i'm probably already dead
as a wheelchair user i am an avid
follower and participant in participant
in adaptive sports and i know sometimes
there is chatter about how an adaptive
athlete has some advantage because they
use specialized equipment when compared
to
regular athletes if we as a human race
got to the point where we had outposts
in space and there was interplanetary
olympics what an athlete who already
knows how to navigate in a compromised
body when compared to able-bodied
athletes have an advantage in
competition would the roles potentially
be reversed and the power athlete be the
one with the perceived advantage
i would totally see that as a real
possibility interesting yeah i mean
yeah
i think what we what we declare to be an
advantage or not
um it's according to some norm that
someone establishes but uh you can
imagine constructing sports
where
whoever was previously advantaged now
becomes disadvantaged i mean you could
you can come up i mean look at how
random sports are anyway take this ball
and put it in a in a hole or in a hoop
or jump or or crawl or kind of like this
okay
so my so i i welcome your your
your follow-up on this charles but
it seems to me
that
we've created a world where
para
para athletes
are trying to do what non-para athletes
what what has been invented and styled
for power athletes imagine a whole set
of competitions designed specifically
for power athletes
and then
then
they have the advantage right so
so so a new world like you say if you go
into space you go into zero g or low g
all all the dynamics changes about who's
good and who's not good at some sport
so that's a that's a that's a
fascinating new world i think it's under
explored
in people's creative ways yeah i have
very little to add to that neil i think
you're 100 right and just our
understanding of what is able
bodied and what is a compromised body
varies with every environment that we go
into new sports are invented all the
time a lot of times we forget right we
were just talking about military patrol
which is no longer being done anymore
but that was a real sport in the 1920s
right
or an advertisement for officers
training school
you don't have to carry the rifle right
the the we should always be adapting to
new places and always looking at human
beings as whole individuals
and when we see what an environment
provides for sport and recreation we
should leap on it and find it and use it
and make it our own regardless of who's
out there and turn into fun that's what
the olympics should be in the end right
fine and the only difference is going
back to what neil said
about the fact that paralympics i mean
para athletes have to do what uh
you know able-bodied athletes do
if it were the other way around
take the able-bodied athlete
and make
them compete
in the same paralympics they lose
every event
like the gentleman that we had on that
shoots uh uh uh who is the archer who
does it with his feet
let any archer try to do that
and they lose right right yeah matt
stutzman was the guy right that's it
that's well remembered neil yes one of
my favorite episodes all right charles
lew fellow astrophysicist geek in chief
and wherever i am on the geek spectrum
he is beyond that
[Laughter]
you are too kind sir all right only on
this show is that a compliment
all right chuck all right gary all right
thank you this has been star talk sports
edition cosmic queries grab bag all
about
winter sports neil degrasse tyson here
keep looking up
[Music]